parfait merci bonjour nous attendons
votre collègue de
Auvergne Rhône-Alpes
madame dubécile est-ce que vous
m'entendez
bonjour
bon écoutez je vous propose néanmoins de
démarrer cette audition mes chers
collègues nous poursuivons cet
après-midi nous auditions des
représentants des associations d'élus
après l'échelon départemental nous
abordons aujourd'hui l'échelon régional
je souhaite donc la bienvenue au Sénat à
Madame fait par visio
pas à Madame Florence Dubessy
vice-président du conseil régional
Auvergne Rhône-Alpes délégué à
l'éducation et au lycée et à madame
Carole canette qui m'entend toujours
absolument fait bien vice-présidente du
conseil régional de centre Val de Loire
délégué au lycée à l'éducation à
l'apprentissage à la Jeunesse et à la
ville lycéenne rien que ça
j'indique à votre attention
madame pour l'instant que notre objectif
est non seulement d'évaluer les besoins
de rénovation des écoles collèges et
lycées liés à la transition écologique
mais aussi d'identifier les défis
notamment au juridique et financiers de
cette rénovation pour les collectivités
territoriales et surtout d'évaluer
l'efficacité de l'accompagnement des
élus locaux s'agissant plus
particulièrement de l'accès à
l'information et à l'expertise
je rappelle également que cette audition
donnera lieu à un compte-rendu écrit qui
sera annexé à notre rapport et que son
enregistrement vidéo sera accessible sur
le site du Sénat un questionnaire vous a
été adressé en amont de cette réunion
nous n'aurons vraisemblablement pas le
temps d'épuiser cet après-midi tous les
sujets qui comportent
c'est en jamais mais vous pourrez
surtout si vous êtes seul ce sera plus
facile pour vous
adresser par la suite des éléments
écrits et enrichir notre réflexion
je vous serai donc reconnaissant lors de
votre exposé de vous limiter à attendre
parole de
15 minutes voir 20 30 minutes la
configuration finale afin de permettre à
temps d'échanges après vos interventions
avant de vous donner la parole notre
rapporteur Nadège avait va vous poser
une première série de questions
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président bonjour
madame canette
merci de prendre le temps effectivement
de nous répondre
juste
on va juste préciser une chose parce
qu'on a oublié de le dire là hier et
Valérie nous a rappelé que c'était
important de le dire qu'il y a un
questionnaire en fait qui à destination
de la consultation des élus qui est
déposé sur la plateforme du Sénat auquel
vous pourrez répondre donc vous pouvez
il va être cette semaine déposée donc
vous pouvez diffuser auprès de auprès de
vos élus également pour qu'on ait une
plus large pour consultation possible je
vais démarrer par un certain nombre de
questions et puis ensuite on verra avec
mes collègues également les différentes
questions qu'on aura à vous à vous à
vous poser je voudrais d'abord savoir au
regard des enjeux écologiques
énergétiques et climatiques les
principaux besoins des lycées en matière
de bâtisse scolaire et les opérations de
réhabilitation les plus urgentes dans
votre région quel est sur ce point la
spécificité en fait liée au lycée
professionnel ou lycée technique comment
qualifier vous l'état de vos lycées au
regard d'une part des enjeux de la
transition écologique et d'autre part
des enjeux relevés par la crise
sanitaire comme la ventilation et la
catilité de l'air et ma dernière
question pour le moment sera
disposez-vous d'informations sur le coût
par mètre carré des opérations de
construction et de rénovation je vous
remercie
alors pour simplifier nos débats que je
perds je vous mets moins de temps
possible dans mes réponses est-ce que
vous pouvez me cibler à quel numéro de
question qui qui nous ont été adressés
cela correspond ça m'évitera de parce
qu'on est un peu travaillé évidemment
pour préparer et ça m'évitera de de
rechercher dans mes documents pour ne
pas oublier les éléments je pourrais
vous faire part alors ce que je vous
propose pour que ce soit plus simple et
comme on a un peu plus de temps vu que
vous êtes la seule interlocutrice
aujourd'hui je vous propose que vous en
fait vous vous fassiez votre
intervention dans le dans le sens que
vous souhaitez et puis nous voilà en
fonction de ce que vous avez préparé
ensuite nous on s'adaptera il y a pas de
souci
d'accord ok
mais déjà
peut-être en introduction vous dire que
ces questions de gestion de l'énergie et
de patrimoine bâti et donc du lien entre
l'état du patrimoine bâti des lycées et
des économies d'énergie
on s'y attelé en région Centre Val de
Loire mais pas seulement l'ensemble des
régions depuis un petit bout de temps
quand même nous n'avons pas entendre
attendu la crise énergétique pour
36 semaines la pleine mesure de
notamment des enjeux nouveaux qui se
profilent devant nous mais en tout cas
la pleine mesure de la nécessité
d'avancer sur sur ces sur ces sujets là
[Musique]
globalement on a avancé c'est
particulièrement en région Centre alors
là pour sur deux sujets le premier je
crois que l'ensemble des régions si
attelées c'est effectivement l'état du
bâti mais il nous a semblé aussi et donc
en région Centre Val de Loire on y a
travaillé depuis un petit bout de temps
que les questions de production de
régulation distribution de chaleur était
extrêmement important on peut
on peut pas travailler sur un volet sans
travailler sur l'autre on peut
travailler à la distribution à la
régulation etc si on a des passoires
énergétiques ça sert pas à grand chose
mais en même temps même dans le bâti tel
qu'il était le fait d'avoir c'est ce
qu'on a fait des contrats de
performances énergétiques
et de travailler à une meilleure
des meilleurs modes de production
production à une meilleure utilisation
de la chaleur en particulier
nous semblait absolument absolument
central donc ça nous on a commencé ce
travail en 2010 et puis on a mis un
deuxième coup d'accélérateur en 2020
donc vous voyez que le sujet n'est pas
un nouveau pour nous néanmoins néanmoins
la tâche est immense absolument
immense on
s'est été donné comme objectif
d'arriver sur des consommations
qui correspondent maintenant aux
objectifs que qui nous sont donnés par
l'état
de gagner 40%
de consommation par rapport à 2010 aux
alentours de 2030 donc ça ce travail là
il a été fait ce qui nous inquiète
fortement en revanche
c'est les deux étapes
ultérieures
qui serait d'arriver à moins 50% de
consommation en 2040 et - 60 en 2050
là on a on a chiffré à peu près ce que
ça
représenterait sur 25 ans
c'est un milliard et demi
donc évidemment ce sont des sommes qui
sont absolument considérables ça fait
environ 50 millions par an aujourd'hui
on investit je vous parlais à l'échelle
de la région Centre-Val de Loire 100
millions d'euros dans les lycées ça veut
dire que il faut qu'on bascule 50 % de
ses sommes uniquement sur la rénovation
énergétique or vous n'êtes pas
évidemment sans savoir que il y a
d'autres investissements qui sont
nécessaires parfois pour construire un
lycée parfois pour des des places aux
techniques des extensions des
rénovations de de
soi de lieux d'enseignement soit de
d'internat on a un vrai sujet avec les
enterrements ou de restauration scolaire
bref
la
détermination est forte mais la tâche
absolument immense
ça c'est le premier point que je voulais
que je vous laisse souligner le deuxième
c'est que on expérimente mais comme je
crois que c'est fait par d'autres
régions différentes
modalités outre le travail sur l'angle
thermique sur l'enveloppe bâti pardon
bâtimentaire on expérimente pour la
gestion de l'énergie différente
modalités on a les CPE on a des lycées
qui sont gérés avec des équipes de la
région pour regarder un petit peu
comment comment les choses fonctionnent
fonctionnent au mieux il nous semble que
l'expérience des contrats de performance
énergétiques
sont particulièrement
intéressante alors elle se double
toujours de premiers travaux
d'investissement sur l'enveloppe
bâtimentaire
à minima
voilà ce que je peux vous dire en
introduction
vous nous interrogiez dans votre
document sur qui nous a été transmis en
amont de cette audition
sur les statistiques concernant les
modes de chauffage de lycée la
répartition entre le gaz le chauffage
urbain le sous le bois on dispose de
de
quelques données à l'échelle de
l'ensemble des régions l'enquête a été
menée par par l'Association des régions
de France au printemps 2022
il semblerait au regard des réponses
qu'on a qui concerne 11 régions
que l'électricité mais voyez les
situations sont très différentes parce
que vous allez voir que
nous on est un peu la région Centre-Val
de Loire est un peu atypique la première
source d'énergie utilisée dans les
lycées et encore la
l'électricité puis vient le gaz et de
manière ponctuelle le fioul
[Musique]
le
on constate aussi un mouvement et je le
vois dans ma région aussi assez fort
pour le raccordement au chauffage urbain
avec donc souvent des systèmes
qui sont alimentés par la biomasse
avec souvent des mélanges entre bois
donc et puis et puis du gaz et de la
proportion bois qui est en train qui est
en train d'augmenter
on est sur des alors c'est pareil on est
un peu atypique on est sur des contrats
de gaz en général qui ont une moyenne
d'un peu moins de trois ans
et qui se répartissent sur voir beaucoup
avec des
au moins une partie de prix bloqués les
contrastes répartissent entre 40% de
prix bloqués
50% à mix bloqué non bloqué et 10% de
prix non bloqué avec on connaît les
effets que ça et on est à peu près dans
la même répartition pour pour
l'électricité des durées de mandat des
durées de de contrats qui sont qui sont
un peu qui sont un peu similaires
tout ça ça se joue je vous le disais
dans dans un contexte de
patrimoine enfin d'État du patrimoine
qui est globalement bon même si je vous
le disais là aussi
l'ampleur de des investissements
nécessaires pour avoir une qualité
optimale en matière de performance
énergétique reste
absolument absolument considérable
puisque c'est on est sur des surfaces
qui sont absolument conséquentes
d'ailleurs on regarde les en général les
les surfaces
par élève on ces dernières années
augmentées même si on commence à avoir
des réflexions intéressantes là je
trouve quand on bâtit de nouveaux lycées
mais globalement les surfaces par élève
sont importantes on a
la surface dont on parle pour l'ensemble
des lycées d'enseignement
général de lycée professionnel de lycée
agricole et maritimes on parle de
quelques 46 millions de mètres carrés
et quand je dis quelques on pourrait
dire 47 millions donc ça veut dire des
investissements extrêmement lourds
encore une fois les régions sont
vraiment engagées résolument dans ce
mouvement là avec quand même quelques
freins qui sont parfois le
manque de visibilité qu'on peut avoir
sur les accompagnements mobilisables
souvent l'état procède par des appels à
projets sur une année alors ça peut être
le fond vert ça peut être
moult dispositif mais nous les régions
on a besoin
de programmer quand on s'attaque à un
parc immobilier de
47 millions de mètres carrés toute
région confondues
ça suppose de programmer les choses et
programmer les choses à partir de nos
seuls budgets ça va être compliqué puis
je rajouterais un élément mais le
programme est en se disant qu'on va
avoir
des appuis des aides des cofinancements
c'est bien mais le travail ne peut être
optimum que si
c'est on a une visibilité sur les aides
on peut disposer y compris d'ailleurs je
parle du gouvernement mais y compris à
l'échelle sur l'échelon européen et puis
parce que un des risques qu'il pourrait
y avoir c'est que nous ne nous
finissions par nous concentrer sur notre
patrimoine
scolaire les lycées donc souvent on est
d'ailleurs je dis ça mais on est de les
lycées sous contrat compression si on
investissement
mais qu'on se concentre sur notre niveau
premier de responsabilité à savoir les
lycées et que
[Musique]
attendez de revoir
le volume dans lequel on accompagne par
ailleurs les autres collectivités sur
leur propre responsabilités pour faire
court on aide aussi les départements
sur la rénovation leur patrimoine
scolaire pour les collèges on est en
appui des collectivités
des communes sur la rénovation leur
patrimoine
pour le niveau primaire et maternel
on le fait à travers des dispositifs
divers selon les régions en centre Val
de Loire c'est par exemple la convention
région départements c'est les contrario
de solidarité territoriales enfin d'un
seul coup on se dit bon la priorité
enfin c'est le cas mais il faut qu'on
concentre nos moyens sur notre
patrimoine le risque c'est qu'on mette
en difficulté les autres collectivités
donc vraiment la question d'avoir une
visibilité sur les cofinancements qui
peuvent y avoir à l'échelon supra région
gionale c'est absolument
c'est absolument central
voilà peut-être parce que c'est pas
c'est pas un risque c'est bien qu'on
puisse faire ce travail là mais on est
face à des enjeux
non seulement il est question d'être
vertueux en termes de consommation
d'énergie il est question mais il est
question aussi d'enjeux financiers
budgétaire sur le fonctionnement on a
j'ai quelques chiffres là sous les yeux
en 2019 on était en je vais vous donner
les chiffres de la région Centre-Val de
Loire consommation d'énergie on était
électrique on était à 5 millions et demi
et 6 millions 7 sur sur le gaz voilà ça
c'est à peu près c'est à peu près le
seul volume parce que il nous reste deux
chaudières fuel enfin c'est tout à fait
anecdotique
aujourd'hui face à ces cinq cinq et ces
systèmes je vais millions je vais vous
donner les chiffres 2022
bah non je vais vous donner même les
projections 2023 on passerait à 22
millions 21,8
dans nos budget de loyer on passe de 12
millions à 22 millions en consommation
d'énergie pour pour notre patrimoine
scolaire donc c'est aussi sur le
fonctionnement et on sait combien les
budgets fonctionnement sont tendus par
quoi donc la tentation elle pourrait
être efficace absolument efficace pour à
la fois parce que ces vertueux à la fois
parce que ça ça vient contraindre si on
fait pas ça vient le contraindre nos
budget de fonctionnement et donc le
risque ça pourrait être qu'on soit moins
en appui des collectivités infras
régionales pour qu'elles continuent à
faire le travail sur leur propre
sur leur propre patrimoine
[Musique]
voilà ce que tout à l'heure excusez-moi
tout à l'heure vous avez dit quand vous
avez parlé des sources d'énergie sur les
11 régions qu'il y avait des
spécificités en fait et vous alliez nous
expliquer lesquels en centre Val de
Loire j'aurais bien aimé connaître
également le nombre de lycées que vous
avez dans votre région
merci et savoir la proportion de ceux
qui ont déjà été en fait rénovés ou pas
est-ce que vous avez et vous ce que vous
en avez une idée et je reviendrai après
sur d'autres questions
oui
alors que je voudrais me trompe pas dans
les chiffres nous la spécificité c'est
qu'on est beaucoup au gaz
beaucoup au chauffage urbain et donc la
question de l'électricité et moins moins
forte qu'ailleurs quand même voilà après
sur les
les documents dispose de de sans lisser
sur je pense à l'échelle nationale on
doit être à 3750 établissements je crois
si on est sur le public et sous contrat
je crois que c'était les données dont on
disposés pour
pour atteindre le niveau
1 de
dispositions nationales de dans notre
stratégie d'ambition on va dire que
[Musique]
quasiment 100% je veux dire 90% de nos
lycées sont traités là parce que on a
on a eu cette vague de contrat de
performance énergétique dès 2010 et à
chaque fois on investit fortement
[Musique]
sur l'enveloppe pour que pour que la
performance énergétique enfin pour que
le travail sur la production la
régulation la distribution de chaleur
soit efficiente qu'on l'a fait en 2010
sur 20 lycées on a mis 30 millions sur
la table pour pour agir sur sur les
enveloppes bâtimentaires et on a réussi
effectivement à réaliser 40% d'économie
aujourd'hui en terme de consommation
donc on l'a fait pour 20 lisser en 2010
on l'a fait pour
60 lycées en 2020
et puis les donc ça fait 80 et les 20
autres on a eu quelques quelques travaux
donc j'allais dire 100% des lycées ont
eu un premier traitement mais si on
parle de l'objectif d'arriver à moins
50% en 2040 là il faut qu'on reprenne
tous nos lycées pour passer de à nouveau
à ce niveau 2 on a 90% des lycées à
traiter
donc inutile de vous dire que c'est la
même chose
j'imagine bien je vous remercie j'avais
quand vous parlez quand vous parliez des
11 régions tout à l'heure avec les en
numéro 1 la source de la source
d'énergie électricité gaz et fuel et ce
qu'il y a une disparité dans les régions
est-ce qu'on a plus d'électricité à
certains endroits de la France et du gaz
à d'autres ou est-ce que c'est vraiment
un peu disparaître je n'ai pas
mon intuition j'ai pas de cartographie
je vous remercie est-ce que mes
collègues à ce niveau-là ont déjà des
questions
vous avez pu déjà dans les lycées que
vous avez construit neuf en construire à
énergie positive
alors non
nous sommes en train de d'en construire
deux là actuellement il y en a un qui va
ouvrir à la à la rentrée prochaine il y
en a dont la première pierre
n'est pas encore posée mais les plantes
sont faits j'allais dire on est sur
avant projet définitif
sur les plans l'avant-projet définitif
qui ont vraiment ont cherché là à chaque
fois il y a rarement une solution
globale parce qu'en fonction du type
d'équipement
on peut avoir un bout du lycée qui va
être en énergie positive mais
pas
entièrement quoi parce que on va on va
vraiment chercher les sources d'énergie
adaptée en fonction de du type de lieu
on va pas avoir la même solution
énergétique pour le gymnase que pour
l'internat où il y a la question de la
production d'eau chaude dans d'autres
volumes que ailleurs que donc on explore
à chaque fois la géothermie on explore
les panneaux solaires et
le solaire loi thermique pour pour l'eau
chaude de l'eau chaude sanitaire en
particulier mais non non on n'arrive pas
à des solutions
[Musique]
le pourcentage ou de ce que vous faites
de rénovation aux constructions neuves
est-ce que vous réhabilitez plus que ce
que vous construisez
madame la vice-présidente sur les vins
lycées que vous avez traités en 2010
puis les 60 autres lycées que vous avez
traité en 2020
considérez-vous qu'il faille tout
refaire ou que les travaux que vous avez
laissez-moi finir c'est le groupe
est-ce que vous considérez avec les
travaux qui ont été réalisés c'est à
valoir sur le sur les travaux qui
restent à faire
parce que
pour atteindre
[Musique]
vous savez c'est toujours les ça marche
qui sont les plus faciles alors là ils
étaient ambitieuses mais ce sont
toujours les premières marches qui sont
les plus faciles à gravir
la l'ambition elle était forte on a
réussi à à être peu
atteindre l'objectif d'une diminution de
40 % de l'énergie en couple en
et l'intervention sur le bâti et la
régulation la production de chaleur nous
on travaille avec avec le groupe Eiffage
et donc des équipes dédiées etc donc
mais mais passer de -40 à -50 ça suppose
de non pas de tout refaire mais mais des
investissements complémentaires quand je
dis il faut c'est 100% enfin il faut
intervenir sur 90% des lycées pour
atteindre les 50%, que c'est c'est pas
partout pareil évidemment ce qui a été
fait n'est pas à reprendre mais le
compléter ça va être ça va être une
sacra faire quoi
question complémentaire est-ce que vous
profitez de ces travaux de rénovation
énergétique pour
traiter d'autres aspects
par exemple sur le sur la le côté
agréable du lycée sur les
sur l'accessibilité sur le sur la
fonctionnalité des lieux vous en
profitez bien sûr j'imagine oui
on a ça fait partie du Castel avec
le l'opérateur
on dit ben voilà
dans l'enveloppe qui vous est donné à la
fois pour réguler pour produire pour
tout ça il y a on a deux une enveloppe
d'investissement pour la rénovation
thermique et là nous on vient en
complément sur des aspects tels que le
cadre de vie et puis pour les vins
lycées qui restent quand on
intervient sur la rénovation thermique
là d'emblée on envisage tous les volets
oui oui pour regarder le cadre de vie
d'autant que on s'appelle aussi à
évidemment quand on pense aux
rénovations thermiques très souvent même
si c'est de moins en moins vrai très
souvent on passe d'hab on pense d'abord
aux dépenses de chauffage et donc au
confort d'hiver mais de plus en plus
n'importe des questions de confort d'été
il y avait une petite question dans
votre questionnaire d'ailleurs sur
est-ce qu'il y a des salles
plus fraîches qui sont prévus etc je
pense que vous allez m'interroger
là-dessus mais on intervient aussi sur
ce champ là dans le cadre de la
rénovation des extérieurs avec les
questions de
revégétalisation des cours
[Musique]
d'imaginer non seulement des îlots de
fraîcheur pour que les élèves puissent
avoir un peu de fraîcheur quand il fait
chaud mais pour avoir une implantation
qui puisse jouer sur le confort en
intérieur
voilà donc on coupe les couples les
choses à la fois
rénovation thermique cadre de vie et
jouer sur le confort d'été à travers ce
cadre de vie notamment quand on est dans
l'extérieur
est-ce que quand vous faites la
réflexion d'un lycée ou que vous le
construisez tout en entier il y a un
travail avec la communauté éducative
également à quel moment à quel moment
ils sont
associés en fait à vos travaux
alors quand on est sur les rénovations
sur les aspects des rénovations
énergétiques le travail il est
essentiellement technique sur la base du
recueil des besoins des utilisateurs
donc ça va être on va travailler avec
les avec la direction avec le
gestionnaire avec nos équipes à nous
pour regarder quels sont les priorités
là où il faut traiter enfin
en revanche quand on est et puis alors
par contre quand on est sur le cadre de
vie on essaie que ce travail là se fasse
avec l'ensemble de la communauté
éducative y compris y compris les
lycéens quand on construit la démarche
est
assez à la fois ambitieuse mais nouvelle
mais ça ça correspond à des mouvements
sociétaux plus larges et plus profonds
qui qui appelle ça
[Musique]
on travaille avec des ateliers de de
participatif qui associe évidemment la
communauté éducative mais pas que pas
que puisqu'on travaille aussi avec les
élus locaux d'une part
et avec par exemple les associations
locales et les
et même les habitants d'une part parce
que on tient à s'assurer
c'est un gage de cela que l'implantation
d'un lycée qui souvent vient quand même
bouleverser le
l'environnement des gens la topographie
il va y avoir des travaux il va y avoir
des routes on était dans un sens on sera
plus un etc donc que le projet soit
accueilli donc on travaille c'est
acceptabilité mais on travaille aussi ça
ça me semble important de le dire parce
que si on devait être accompagné plus
soit par l'État soit par
prendre des fonds européens c'est non
seulement pour ce serait non seulement
pour
nous accompagner sur notre propre
patrimoine où se passe les actes
éducatifs mais aussi parce que
maintenant les les on cherche à ouvrir
notre patrimoine pour qu'ils profitent
aux autres acteurs je crois que c'est
fini le temps où on construisait un
gymnase pour un lycée qui fonctionnait
de 8h du matin jusque 18h les semaines
scolaires et qui étaient fermés et qui
ne servira à rien pendant les week-ends
les vacances scolaires et puis à côté on
bâtirait un collègue un pardon un
gymnase
la collectivité la vie commune bâtirait
un gymnase pour mettre à disposition de
ces associations notamment pour les
tournois le week-end et c'est fini c'est
chose là je pense que donc la question
de la mutualisation des équipements et
je pense que c'est intéressant aussi sur
la conception de de la place du lycée
dans la vie de la cité parce que ça
permet de l'ouvrir également et donc de
faire tomber des représentations des
barrières etc
la mutualisation des équipements est
aujourd'hui une préoccupation forte mais
à mon avis ça justifie d'autant plus que
[Musique]
l'ensemble des financeurs puissent être
au rendez-vous parce qu'il y a cette
démarche là il me semble extrêmement
vertueuse
merci vous m'offrez une transition toute
facile
vous parlez de mutualisation des
équipements on a rencontré la semaine
dernière des représentants des
enseignants
français à l'étranger et on a parlé en
fait de la conception des lycées
français à l'étranger
je ne me souviens plus c'était à Madrid
ou je ne sais plus où il y en a qui est
effectivement en construction avec cette
vision de l'inclure dans la ville et
qu'il soit ouvert pour qu'il puisse
effectivement c'était assez vide me
suivre flotton qui puisse effectivement
être aussi ouvert aux habitants qui qui
pourraient qui pourraient y passer ou y
découvrirait un certain nombre de choses
et je voulais savoir si vous avez un
échange en fait avec leur façon de faire
et notamment tous tout ce qu'ils font de
bien au niveau de la construction par
rapport à tout ce qui est canicule ou
ou dans les dans les endroits où il fait
vraiment très chaud et savoir si vous
avez une remontée avec des bonnes
pratiques ou si c'est quelque chose
qu'il faudrait accentuer parce que les
différents architectes aujourd'hui
seront peut-être confrontés demain à
démonter de température plus importante
et on aurait peut-être besoin de
s'inspirer de ce qui se fait chez nous
mais à l'étranger
alors non on n'a pas d'échange de bonnes
pratiques mais vous avez c'est une piste
qui me semble très intéressante et je
pense que
c'est une
proposition que je vais faire à l'ARF
parce que ça me semble effectivement
très intéressant
notamment sur la gestion des fortes
chaleurs
pour ce qui est de la mutualisation
alors
oui on le fait non seulement on l'a on
l'a en tête mais
c'est pas seulement une question d'usage
cette possibilité de d'usage partagé
alors elle suppose un travail de
sensibilisation parce que la communauté
éducative n'y est pas toujours très
prête sur le principe oui mais mais il
faut régler des questions de
de craindre de responsabilité si un
accident de oui mais est-ce que tel
équipement il peut fonctionner
sans sentier du personnel de la région
parce que moi nous on veut bien prêter
nos équipements enfin si ça vient agir
sur la masse salariale parce qu'il faut
du personnel en plus faut peut-être voir
qui est absorbe ça et mais surtout ça se
pense dès la conception il y a des
lycées pour les qui sont construits de
longue date et pour lesquelles la top
topographie des lieux fait que c'est
compliqué en revanche aujourd'hui je le
dis là on a on construit de lycée un des
critères quand on retient les projets
c'est d'avoir intégré cette enjeu là et
donc la manière dont on tourne tel
équipement que le lycée ou l'amphi ou la
salle de conférence ou la petite salle
de spectacle soit tournée vers
l'extérieur que les parkings soient
proches qui est pas besoin de rentrer au
cœur du lycée pour accéder à ses
équipements pour que ils puissent y
avoir une porosité entre la cité et ses
équipements sans que ça vienne inquiéter
la communauté éducative
on l'a dès la conception dès la
rédaction des des
premiers documents qui vont présider à
la à l'élaboration du projet définitif
mais je retiens je retiens la suggestion
de nous tourner vers les lycées français
de l'étranger notamment pour imaginer
des choses s'inspirer de leur bonne
pratique concernant le l'effort chaleur
à la fois sur les projets
bâtimentaires
enfin sur les nouveaux projets mais à la
fois sur sur les rénovations
sur les rénovations ou les
ajustements les adaptations des lieux
dont on dispose déjà on va vous remettre
les coordonnées des personnes qu'on a
auditionné ça peut être effectivement
une piste j'aurais aimé également avoir
votre avis
sur s'il y avait la création d'un
opérateur auquel serait confiée la
mission de coordonner l'accompagnement
des collectivités qu'ils souhaitent
évidemment dans la conduite de projets
de rénovation énergétique sous forme de
guichet unique est-ce que c'est quelque
chose qui vous paraîtrait intéressant ou
pas du tout puisque dans le
fonctionnement aujourd'hui tout
fonctionne très bien
alors je vais vous répondre oui mais pas
important la casquette qui fait nous
avons cet échange aujourd'hui je
m'explique
les je suis par ailleurs mère
de la commune de Fleury-les-Aubrais je
dans le Loiret
en tant que vice-présidente du conseil
régional je vais vous dire et même que
représente de l'ARF j'aurais tendance à
vous dire
les régions se sont engagées dans ce
travail depuis longtemps on a des
équipes structurées
on a les moyens de faire cette cette
ingénierie et on l'a fait donc
ce guichet unique
en tant que vice-président du conseil
régional
[Musique]
ne me mets pas quelques étoiles dans les
yeux en revanche en tant que mère oui
vous devriez revenir demain à notre
audition sur avec les élus locaux alors
et pour les départements je
m'avance je m'avance parce que je veux
département
mais je pense qu'ils sont plutôt dans la
même configuration que les régions la
commune
[Musique]
les régions que les régions ils ont un
patrimoine
important ils ont les moyens
de d'avoir des équipes
solides je pense que le travail est fait
quoi le travail d'ingénierie d'imaginer
ils ont ils ont des des interlocuteurs
comme les régions
habituelles on a
ouais on sait faire on sait faire que
les régions je pense que les
départements aussi en revanche les
communes je crois que c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué
pour certaines ou pour une au moins
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué mais pour
partager avec nos collègues c'est
largement répandu et je pense que c'est
tout le monde vous dira ça à part les
très grosses métropole combien il y a
d'habitants dans votre commune
j'ai trouvé que puisque on a auditionné
la DF hier que la DF était même plus
sévère que vous en direction de l'État
elle a eu des commentaires un peu plus
musclés est-ce que vous avez entendu
parler du guide
édité par
l'Éducation nationale sur le bâti
scolaire
en tout cas vous n'avez pas eu besoin
je vais pas vu
il arrive avec
avec
retard
il est et puis il est
comme on dit si j'en ai bons souvenirs
il est un recueil presque des attentes
des
usagers plus qu'un guide pour les
collectivités
et donc si ce guide avait été
orienté plus pour nous dire et comment
on peut
faire le filtre adapté nos
fonctionnements pour
ne pas juste
[Musique]
comment dire pour ne pas juste
parce que là on a
pas qui sont pas
qui sont pas filtrés qui sont pas
accompagnés donc ce voilà franchement ce
guide là moi je n'en a pas besoin
voilà qui est clair dites-moi sur les
100 lycées qui relèvent de votre
responsabilité il y en a sans doute je
passe le contrôle de Jean-Paul prince
qui vous salue il y en a sans doute qui
a
sont des bâtiments classés au sens des
monuments historiques
c'est bien ça Jean-Paul
est-ce que l'intervention sur ce type de
bâtiment
revient beaucoup plus cher que sur celle
qu'on peut constater sur les bâtiments
classiques traditionnels
oui oui ça revient toujours plus cher
quand on est sur
quand on est sur moi je n'ai pas je n'ai
pas et on ne m'a pas remonté de
problématique particulière
[Musique]
sur ce sujet là mais je pense pas que ce
soit parce que ça n'existe pas je pense
que c'est parce que tous les élus savent
que dès lors qu'on intervient sur du
patrimoine c'est comme je me suis là
c'est pas propre au lycée
on a toujours ces problématiques
[Musique]
oui c'est plus cher oui il y a la
question de la BF oui voilà
votre votre collègue
Auvergne Rhône-Alpes est toujours
pas là
on me le confirme si j'ai bien compris
ce que vous avez ce site commun avec les
départements et sans doute avec les
maires de France le principal obstacle
c'est le financement compte tenu du
calendrier
qui lui faisait non pas proposé mais
d'une certaine manière imposée
oui il y a le financement
de
les capacités
à faire et là c'est pas une question
d'une d'une
cellule d'un bûcher unique et tout ça
c'est vraiment d'aller faire il faut
aller faire les diagnostics dire bon on
va sur celui-là plutôt que sur celui-là
etc donc les capacités à faire de nos
équipes ça supposerait sûrement un
renforcement de des équipes dédiées à ça
en interne mais surtout les capacités à
faire du territoire c'est à dire que on
est parfois confronté à des travaux qui
sont reportés parce que il y a pas les
entreprises
n'ont pas non pas les
ressources humaines nécessaires pour
mener ces travaux voilà si on si on
passe la vitesse supérieure il y a
certains problèmes de budget il va y
avoir aussi un problème de d'équipe
interne mais surtout surtout
le budget et surtout la capacité à faire
des entreprises
qui travaillent sur les lycées genre
Bouygues pour choses comme ça ou des
entreprises régionales
alors même quand c'est Bouygues en fait
ça sous-traite donc ce sont des
entreprises au bout du bout ce sont des
entreprises régionales
vous n'êtes pas la première à nous le
dire les représentants des départements
hier nous le nom de dîmes et la semaine
dernière on avait une une audition avec
la Fédération française du bâtiment et
avec la CAPEB et en fait on a bien
assisté sur la capacité à faire et ce
qui nous est remonté c'était il y avait
pas il y a pas de problème
[Musique]
a-t-elle échéance on peut se préparer à
répondre ou pas et puis c'est le moment
de d'échanges sur sur entre les
collectivités et les et les opérateurs
économiques et cette question là était
ressortait et pas de la part des élus de
la part des entreprises maintenant je
comprends aussi qu'à certains niveaux il
le fasse pas forcément remonter parce
que je pense qu'il voudrait pas qu'on
renonce à à une ambition qui préfère
qu'il y ait des marchés et pas pouvoir y
répondre plutôt qu'il n'y ait pas de
marché donc je pense qu'il y a un peu de
ça néanmoins je je
est-ce qu'elle devise présidente mais
sur un autre
domaine de compétences ça veut dire que
il faut qu'on
prépare le pays à cela
pour qu'on prépare nos territoires et
nos régions mais plus globalement qu'on
prépare nos pays assis donc la question
des cartes de formation et du travail
qu'on peut mener avec l'Éducation
nationale pour avoir
pour s'assurer qu'on se donne des
compétences nécessaires en région
c'est absolument central et on a
parfois un peu de mal à le faire avec
l'Éducation nationale dans une approche
pluriannuelle je dis ça il y a
absolument pas de mise en cause de des
autorités
académiques de ma région qu'on a un
nouveau rectangle avec lequel la
collaboration semble pouvoir se passer
le mieux du monde
mais mais il y a quelques comment dire
approche à modifier on a parfois
l'impression quand on travaille les
cartes de formation que on est dans la
gestion pas forcément à long terme en
tout cas c'est ce que c'est ce que j'ai
pu moi expérimenté je pense que c'est en
train de changer mais c'est central dire
que la question c'est pas bon bah quelle
formation on ouvre demain c'est comment
on prépare notre territoire pour avoir
les compétences et donc alors c'est
toujours compliqué les cartes de
formation vous savez on regarde où on
ouvre une formation on enfermé mais mais
là où on en ouvre une bah ça peut
générer des flux qui vont en fragiliser
une autre ailleurs à 30 km de là etc
mais on a parfois l'impression que
l'éducation nationale le fait à partir
de ces
[Musique]
de sa vision qu'elle a de l'équipe
éducative en place quoi moi on m'a
parfois dit non mais cette formation là
faut la fermer je comprenais pas bien
pourquoi bah c'est parce que l'équipe
éducative en place et pas au top ben non
on essaie de se si on considère que les
compétences elles sont nécessaires de
les construire on se donne d'une équipe
éducative qui fonctionne enfin pas une
formation juste pour ça
si on les
le territoire se dit que il faut former
au métier de demain sur la rénovation
thermique énergétique sur les
régulations de sur les régulations de de
d'énergie dans dans les bâtiments sur la
recherche il faut le faire enterrer dans
les territoires aussi
j'ai une question sur la stratégie qui
est la vôtre compte tenu du travail que
vous avez déjà accompli depuis 2010
pour
mettre les niveaux les lycées à
un niveau progressivement
compte tenu de la capacité financière
qui est la vôtre et s'il devait ne pas
changer demain il vous reste à faire
d'ici 2050 quelques 40 lycées qui n'ont
pas encore été qui n'ont pas fait
l'objet de travaux et quel que soit son
lycée qui ont déjà fait les travaux quel
choix ferez-vous quel choix feriez-vous
est-ce que vous irez par exemple amener
les lycées que vous n'avez pas encore
traité à 60% d'économies tout de suite
sur les sur les 40 le lycées qui n'ont
pas été traités ou est-ce que vous
opérerez en tenant compte d'autres
critères tels que la répartition
géographique
dans la région
est-ce que
vous dernière question j'ai compris le
contexte je veux pas répondre vous savez
il vous reste en gros 40 lycées qui
n'ont pas été traités du tout je les
sens
qui font l'objet d'un contrat de
performance énergétique dans et dans le
cadre de cette démarche on a mis 30
millions sur la table
pour la rénovation énergétique et
ensuite en 2020 il y a 20 lycées mais
vous allez voir comme quoi il y a 20
lycées et ont pardon 2020 il y a 60
lycées donc ça fait quatre ans pour
lesquels pour la rénovation énergétique
on a mis je vais aller dire seulement
même si ça reste des sommes
considérables 32 millions sur la table
mais ça veut dire on a mis pour 60
lycées la même somme que pour 20 10 ans
avant quand même
et donc votre question lesquelles on
allait traiter en premier oui c'est à
dire est-ce que vous allez traiter en
premier les vagues qu'il reste à traiter
et les pour les amener à 60% d'économies
d'ici 2050 mais est-ce que vous allez
saupoudrer un peu davantage l'effort
pour traiter l'ensemble des lycées qui
restent certains plus fortement que
d'autres puisqu'ils sont ils sont ils
partent de zéro
alors les
[Musique]
banques absolument pas été traitées
simplement on l'a pas fait dans le cadre
d'un contrat de performance énergétique
mais ils ont été traités également
de manière moins globale on pourrait
dire
mais mais ils l'ont été je vous le
disais on a 100%
de nos lycées qui ont été qui ont eu qui
ont fait l'objet d'un premier traitement
donc là pour répondre à votre question
je pense que les premiers qu'il faudrait
reprendre c'est quand même les 20% de
lycée qui reste et une partie du du parc
des 60 lycées là de la deuxième vague
[Musique]
je suis je suis pas en mesure de vous
répondre sur la méthodologie qu'on
adapterait pour fixer les priorités
merci
est-ce que des collègues souhaitent même
leur rapporteur
je finis avec mes deux autres questions
tout à l'heure vous avez évoqué des
sales fraîches ou la canicule les îlots
de chaleur est-ce que vous pouvez
revenir sur sur ces détails et
je voudrais savoir aussi on a parlé des
lycées en général mais il y a-t-il une
spécificité lycée professionnel et
notamment est-ce que vous avez une idée
du coût entre rénover un lycée
professionnel et un lycée d'enseignement
plus classique j'ai envie de dire
le coût au mètre carré il est à peu près
le même la difficulté avec les lycées
professionnels
c'est plus qu'on a on va avoir des on a
besoin
de température différente selon la
nature des espaces le fameux 19 degrés
dans les salles de cours
sont pas les mêmes enfin on n'a pas
cette exigence là dans les ateliers je
crois qu'on est à 16 degrés dans les
ateliers
encore faut-il que ces ateliers donc ça
suppose un travail plus fin peut-il que
ces ateliers ne soient pas en réalité
des salles de cours où on passe une
demi-heure je sais pas sur un moteur ou
sur une machine ou sur un des
équipements électriques et puis ensuite
une demi-heure assis autour du table
parce que là ça veut dire que même dans
ces ateliers il faut il faut 19 degrés
et là et les choses deviennent
deviennent difficiles
pour le travail bâtimentaire c'est à peu
près c'est pas beaucoup plus compliqué
que dans un lycée d'enseignement général
la question elle est plus de la
régulation d'énergie parce que on va
avoir des de comment aussi prendre pour
réguler l'énergie parce que on va avoir
des besoins différents d'une d'un espace
à l'autre qui souvent sont dans les
mêmes bâtiments donc c'est la question
des sondes des des mécanismes de
régulation et tout ça
ça c'est facile vous avez les salles
elles sont en couloir après on chauffe
pas de la même manière et on régule pas
entre les salles et de la même manière
entre les salles de cours et les
gymnases bon dans le lycée professionnel
il y a cette question des ateliers qui
se posent
plus de questions alors sur
[Musique]
une petite alerte quand même c'est que
je ne connais pas de lycée il y en a
peut-être mais je suis pas certaine
qu'il soit en mesure d'accueillir
des sessions d'examens en période de
canicule qu'on peut très facilement
imaginer au mois de juin maintenant
voire même en mai en tout cas des
périodes de fortes chaleurs et qui soit
capable de d'offrir des espaces
climatisés pour retenir les examens dans
des bonnes conditions on peut
éventuellement avoir une salle ça arrive
mais c'est franchement pas la règle
voilà où il va y avoir de la clim mais
enfin la clim c'est ni la clé ni parfois
on doit avoir une pompe à chaleur ok RR
tu peux rafraîchir un peu de plus en
plus sur les lycées neufs les les
architectes emploient des techniques de
ventilation naturelle qui vont jouer un
peu sur la chaleur mais en fonction des
températures mais enfin on est loin de
de pouvoir garantir et tenues d'examen
dans les conditions
adéquates en période de forte chaleur
merci
merci beaucoup madame canette moi j'ai
une dernière question qu'est-ce qui vous
paraîtrait pertinent
utile de rajouter dans le rapport que
vous n'auriez pas encore dit
je voulais dire la question
de qui peut être offert aux régions et
aussi aux autres collectivités sur les
sur les cofinancements
qui peuvent être ouvert on a besoin de
programmer notre travail aller chez le
plus rien annuelle et donc on peut pas
vivre au gré d'appel à projets comme ça
et d'y répondre enfin c'est pas comme
sur un tel chantier ça ne peut pas
marcher comme ça et si on ne le fait pas
pour les régions le risque c'est que on
se replie sur notre propre patrimoine et
qu'on puisse moins être à l'appui des
collectivités
infras régionales alors que
alors que on aime bien faire ça mais ça
pourrait être le risque
[Musique]
l'idée financement à la fois détails à
la fois européen
c'est une priorité partagée par de
nombreuses collectivités merci beaucoup
pour votre disponibilité et pour votre
pour votre apport dans ce
long cheminement qui va mener jusqu'à la
production du rapport final bonne
après-midi à une prochaine fois avec
plaisir en tout cas vous verrez un grand
plaisir monsieur Jean-Paul Le Prince
bon après-midi au revoir
merci
à vous au revoir
[Musique]
nous terminions à votre vous avez
rencontré un problème technique
tout à fait qui n'a pas réussi à être
résolu et je le regrette vraiment
sincèrement je suis sincèrement désolée
de ce qui vient de se passer parce que
j'avais tellement hâte de participer
j'avais beaucoup de choses à dire sur
cette dans la région vers Rhône-Alpes
donc sincèrement désolé veuillez
accepter écouter madame
écoutez madame la vice-présidente on
vous propose aussi vous en êtes d'accord
bien sûr de reprogrammer cette audition
mais puis avec votre collègue vous seul
du coup parce que on va pas recommencer
elle a elle a fait sa part si je puis
dire parce que là nous pouvons pas
continuer parce que nous avons les
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement et
comme vous le savez c'est obligatoire
donc on prendra contact avec vous
que j'accepte bien sûr volontiers en
vous renouvellement en nous voulons
toutes mes excuses merci beaucoup merci
à vous au revoir au revoir au revoir à
tous